so when I was a young kid I made a lot
of money selling baseball cards and
comic books and toys and then I started
working for my dad's business and I was
making you know it when I was 22 to 28 I
was making thirty five to fifty five
thousand dollars a year but I had no
expenses I didn't go on vacations
I didn't buy fancy things so I saved my
money I saved my money I saved my money
and then when the till you know I had
hundreds of thousands of dollars I
didn't have millions and by the time I
was 33 34 when I had that opportunity I
still not bought a home I was still in
an apartment I was 33 years old and I
was renting and because I was saving
cash to go on the offense and so when I
had a chance to invest in those
companies I put hundreds of thousands of
dollars not millions but those hundreds
made millions made tens of millions and
so that's it nothing crazy nothing I
didn't have any crazy crazy advantage
there's a lot of people that make fifty
five thousand dollars a year when
they're 23 the problem is they go to
Coachella and they want to buy a watch
and they want to buy a BMW and I didn't
so I ate [ __ ] for thirteen years and
then I had a moment and I struck
[Music]